und jetzt das heute journal
um gottes willen dieser mann kann nicht
an der macht bleiben sagt joe biden
heute abend das klingt als ob amerikas
präsident aufruft zum sturz von wladimir
putin guten abend beiden hat eine rede
gehalten in polen vor dem königlichen
schloss zur warschau die es in sich hat
selbst langgediente amerikanische
politbeobachter danach beeindruckt und
verwundert zugleich und der präsident
appelliert an europa es sollte sich
wappnen für einen langen kampf gegen
russische aggression natalie steger ist
in warschau joe biden auf dem weg zu
seiner rede in warschau die in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen dürfte es
folgt eine verbale abrechnung mit dem
kremlchef die ukraine werde nie ein
opfer russlands werden
habt keine angst ein diktator der ein
imperium wieder aufbauen will kann
niemals die freiheitsliebe des volkes
auslöschen
scharfe rhetorik zum abschluss seiner
polenreise die russische bevölkerung
aber sei nicht der feind
russland stranguliert die demokratie
nicht nur zu hause sondern will das auch
anderswo tun unter dem falschen vorwand
der ethnischen solidarität hat das
angrenzende nationen für ungültig
erklärt
beiden entschlossenheit hatte sich zuvor
beim bilateralen treffen mit polens
staatspräsident angedeutet
demonstrativer schulterschluss mit polen
ist frontstadt geworden befürchtet
selbst ziel russische aggression zu
werden beiden sicher die nato
bündnistreue
wir sehen das als heilige verpflichtung
artikel 5 darauf können sie sich
verlassen ihre freiheit ist unser luft
auch beim besuch tagsüber bei
ukrainischen flüchtlingen und helfern
wird beiden deutlich er hört sich ihre
geschichten an wird dann gefragt was er
denke wenn er sehe was und in den
menschen angetan habe
er ist ein schlechter antwortet er der
kreml reagierte empört diplomatische
annäherung sei nun erschwert nach seiner
rede am abend macht sich beiden wieder
auf den weg nach washington nach einem
mehr als denkwürdigen auftritt in polen
el mati wissen begleitet den
us-präsidenten für uns elmar beiden hat
putin erst einen lügner genannt dann
einen schlechter heute dann gesagt
präsident putin kann nicht an der macht
bleiben ist denn regime wechsel jetzt
das neue ziel der usa
also das weiße haus ruderte eifrig
zurück und sagt man hier nein der
präsident habe nicht zum sturz putins
aufgerufen er wollte nur sagen dass
putin keine macht ausüben darf über
seine nachbarländer demzufolge wäre das
dann im grunde um eine abweichung von
manuskript gewesen aus dem handgelenk
heraus formuliert aber vielleicht so
haben wir den eindruck war es ja doch
absicht weil der tag war sehr emotional
und diese worte um gottes willen putin
oder dieser mann kann nicht an der macht
bleiben kann man ja auch als moralisches
urteil verstehen das sicherlich sehr
viele menschen teilen werden wie auch
immer es war wladimir putin kann diese
worte natürlich jetzt als beweis nehmen
dass die nato das der westen eigentlich
immer schon seinen sturz wollte und
insofern hat joe biden möglicherweise
mit diesen worten taktisch sehr unklug
gehandelt interessante analyse helmer
herzlichen dank nach warschau in prag
haben heute russen die in tschechien
leben gegen den ukraine krieg
protestiert etwa 3000 menschen waren
dabei unter dem motto russen gegen putin
die veranstalter wollen damit
klarstellen dass nicht alle russen
heimliche unterstützer des kreml chef
sein
und im geschundenen osten der ukraine
das angebot eines hohen
polizeikommandeurs an die russischen
angreifer er würde sich selbst
eintauschen sein eigenes leben geben
wenn den kindern seiner stadt die flucht
ermöglicht würde ein sicherer weg nach
draußen wenn diese kinder nicht jetzt
gerettet werden schreibt er dann werden
sie in den kommenden tagen sterben und
auch in anderen orten der ukraine heute
mutige zeichen des widerstands und neue
angriffe oliver reichert
mit ihrer flagge demonstrieren diese
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer gegen die
besatzer gehen gegen die russen auf die
straße obwohl die gerade ihre stadt /
eingenommen haben
subotic schlägt im norden der ukraine in
der nähe der atomruine tschernobyl die
kleinstadt wurde nach der
reaktorkatastrophe in der nähe des akw
gebaut für die mitarbeiter der anlage
den protest bekommen die russischen
soldaten nicht wirklich in den griff der
bürgermeister der kurzzeitig gefangen
genommen wird tritt vor seinen bürgern
auf und versichert das sei alles in
ordnung so weit man das unter besatzung
sagen können die russische
militärführung berichtet derweil vor
allem von luftangriffen
unter anderem diese vier geschosse
werden abgefeuert die marschflugkörper
starten von einem schiff auf dem
schwarzen meer nach steht um hier
innerhalb von 24 stunden haben unsere
streitkräfte 117 militärische objekte in
der ukraine getroffen
am nachmittag schlagen zwei oder drei
russische raketen in lemberg ein und
setzen ein tanklager in brand die
menschen bringen sich in schutzräumen in
sicherheit
lemberg liegt im westen der ukraine 80
kilometer von polen entfernt
die lemberger herren den abend in
kellern aus der bürgermeister von
lemberg spricht von fünf verletzten in
der stadt halten sich zurzeit rund
200.000 flüchtlinge aus anderen teilen
der ukraine auf
und jetzt weitere wichtige nachrichten
an diesem samstag gebündelt von hanna
und da blicken wir zuallererst auf ein
ehemaliges prestige-projekt der csu vor
knapp drei jahren wurde die pkw maut vom
europäischen gerichtshof gekippt nun hat
ein schiedsgericht entschieden die
damals vorgesehenen betreiberfirmen
haben einen anspruch auf schadensersatz
das bundesverkehrsministerium will die
schied entscheidung nun prüfen die
genaue höhe des anspruchs ist noch klar
die betreiberfirmen fordern vom bund 560
millionen euro
die rechte von frauen in afghanistan
werden weiter eingeschränkt und haben
die regierenden taliban ein flugverbot
für afghanen verhängt die ohne männliche
begleiter reisen erst mitte der woche
hatten die islamisten für empörung
gesorgt weil sie mädchen den besuch
weiterführender schulen verwehrt haben
mehrere dutzend frauen und mädchen
gingen heute in kabul auf die straße um
gegen diese entscheidung zu protestieren
und wir blicken auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen das robert koch institut meldet
rund
252.000 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind gut 8200 weniger als vor einer
woche
278 todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben
tage incidents steigt auf 1.700 58,4
licht aus um ein zeichen zu setzen für
klima und umweltschutz aber auch für den
frieden das ist die idee hinter der
mauer rund um den globus gegen heute um
20.30 für eine stunde die lichter aus
bekannte wahrzeichen gehüllt in
dunkelheit auch das brandenburger tor
war mit dabei insgesamt haben sich laut
umweltstiftung wwf weltweit mehr als
7000 städte an der aktion beteiligt und
jetzt die lottozahlen von diesem samstag
die lauten 14 16 19 45 46 48 superzahl 4
alle angaben ohne gewähr
es gibt noch der blick auf die
wetteraussichten
morgen halten sich nördlich des mains am
vormittag auf dichte wolken zum
nachmittag hin gibt es dann mehr sonne
bei 12 bis 17 grad im süden bleibt es
wolkenlos hier werden 17 bis 22 grad
erreicht
am montag überwiegt noch der
sonnenschein ab dienstag dann die wolken
regen kommt auch dazu und von norden her
wird es kühler
ja das war in aller kürze unsere welt an
diesem samstag dank dass sie dabei waren
viel spaß jetzt weiterhin beim fußball
und ihnen ein angenehm haben
[Musik]